You have to be very careful with praise.
Oh yeah.
Because in the example that I give in
the corner of MMA fights is if you tell a
guy, hey, good job. You know you're
well, you won that last round.
Keep just keep doing what you're doing.
He's going to back off.
He's going to back off. And guess
what the other corners telling him,
you lost that round. You need to step
it up. You need to get aggressive.
And that's what they're gonna do.
They're gonna get out there.
Because I'll tell you,
most people in an MMA fight,
MMA fight is a, it's like wrestling.
It's a very intense cardio activity.
You're good. Everybody's going to be
tired, beat just about everybody knew,
obviously. So when you get two guys,
well let me, let me rephrase that.
When you get two guys that are evenly
matched and are going at it hard,
they're both going to be tired. And so
they're gonna want a little bit of a rest.
So can you give them that opportunity to
back off the throttle just a little bit.
Subconsciously they're going to do it
because they think they're doing good.
They think that one that last round, so
you can see that all the time. You see,
I mean it happened, it happened with
Rhonda, you know, they're saying, hey,
good job, good job. You're looking
good and she's getting crushed.
I mean, that's kind of a bad example. But
anyways, you gotta be careful of that.
And I've told this story before,
but when my tasking was going
through training and uh,
we will doing CQC, so close
quarters, combat drills,
we're going in a kill house
over and over and you know,
we broke for lunch or something.
We come back from lunch and the guy
that is Kadri, they're like, hey,
you guys are kicking ass. This is great.
Keep it up. You guys are two best task.
You know, we've seen out here,
you guys are crushing it.
And literally the next run guys go in
the house, they screw everything up,
they miss targets, just a disaster.
And I talked to the contrary. I'm like,
don't ever tell my guys again that
they're the best guys in the world. Don't.
Don't tell them that.
You can tell them good job,
but don't be telling them they're
the best people in the world.
Just doesn't work. And so that's
kind of what happened. You know here.
Now the thing is,
this doesn't mean that you can never
give anybody credit or never give anyone
praise, because you absolutely have
to do that. But what you have to do,
you have to proactively counter act the
mental lapse and intensity that's about
to take place because you just
compliment them. So how do you do that?
So let's say you're on the
lacrosse field or the soccer field,
you bring the boys in. You say, look
guys, good half good. First half.
You took it to them. You showed
them that we can hang with them.
You played him even. That's
fine. Here's the problem.
Even isn't good enough.
We need to get out there and play harder.
We need to step it up. I actually
want you guys to play like murderers.
That's what I want you to do.
I want you to win every loose ball.
I want you to make every tackle.
I want you to get your head on
every ball that's in the air.
You stick to them on defense. I don't
even want them to be able to breathe.
I want you to work them into the ground.
I want pressure, pressure, upfront,
pressure in the midfield
and pressure on d.
You make them fight for every inch,
every bell and every breath.
I want you to go out there
and take their souls.
So you got to counter that. You know,
you've got to counter the good job thing.
So in MMA it's the same
thing. You know, hey,
good around who was a close round
but a good round. But listen,
you can't let up right now. You need to
step it up. He knows he has to step it up.
I'm telling you, he knows he's got to
step it up. And if you come out week,
he's going to get the upper hand
right away. You need to put him away.
You need to go out there and crush him,
crush his soul,
turn it on and put this guy away.
I want you to kill him.
So that's what you need to do with that.
Now for tactical training,
same thing, cause you know,
I know this police officer's and Swat
teams and t and guys that are in the
military,
you're doing tactical training all the
time and you're going to see that as the
team comes together, they're going
to start to do good. But like I said,
if you give them too much,
okay,
they're going to slack,
right?
So you know when you're running your
tactical training, you for your guys,
you say, look, hey guys, I see
some good progress out there.
We're making some good runs.
But let me tell you it's not
good enough for it right now.
Okay?
This is the deal. The enemy can rely on
luck. We can't, we rely on our training.
We trained to be prepared for
anything that the enemy throws at us.
So we're going to work as hard as
we can and be as perfect as we can.
So we are ready for the
worst case scenario.
So get jacked up for
another run right now.
And I want you to go in there like a
band of bloodthirsty viking shock troops,
all our damn berserker
rage and crush this.
So you want to bring that
kind of calendar right?
And then in combat again,
and I just was talking to some guys
yesterday and it's the same thing where
complacency is the worst thing that can
happen with your team when you're in a
combat scenario. So when you're in
combat, you know it's look, hey guys,
we're running some good operations,
right?
We got the upper hand and that's good,
but it's not good enough.
We cannot be complacent and we can't
take our foot off the enemy's throat.
We are going to be relentless.
We are not going to give
him the chance to regroup.
He will not get the chance to recover.
There will be no downtime for the enemy.
And I'll tell you what,
I don't even want the enemy to
have a chance to bury their dead.
We are not going to stop until there was
left to pursue and no one left to bury.
So sharpen up your knives, load up your
magazines, because we got work to do.
So again, we got to counter, you know,
the compliments in balance.
Essentially what I'm doing in
each one of those situations,
I'm balancing the positive affirmations
of what is happening with some new goals
and new objectives that will ensure
that there will be no slack. No.